you coco fans
the movie kokomo
[Laughter]
that could have meant cocoa poops
a movie coco
i love that movie i
i was thinking now you know the movie's
named coco which is the i will lead this
name right okay but you you see her how
many times in the movie
like twice and they named the whole
feature film after coco mama coco but
you only see her twice
i see her once in the chair at the
beginning at the end when she goes
remember me and died
don't name the movie coco you don't even
have her in there name it miguel it's
about the little boy
if i were mama coco i'd be pissed
just just follow me on this okay i would
i would be mo if i were mama coco i'd
march in a pixar just like
hey what the hell
i'm so pissed
so it's not fair you know like i'm cool
i got a story
you name a whole movie after me but i'm
not in it
it doesn't make sense you got what's
that movie wally
he's in every shot
that's a robot
ratatouille
he's even in the food
it's not fair i'm pissed
you know what
the only way you can make it up to me
pigs are makeup coco too
go back in time and tell my story
go back to my college days
the university
like go back to her party days you know
she's just in her dorm
guys coming over
hey come here
you want some of this hot cocoa
i did a lot of cocaine